well shopping is starting to look a lot
different this christmas a famous
complex in los angeles resembling a war
zone with barbed wire like fencing being
put up to stop potential smash and grab
thieves now while local officials blame
the problem on no bail policies the
white house is still refusing to take a
strong stance on that
i am not as i as i wasn't yesterday
going to give an assessment for every uh
every in every motivation or reason for
crime in different communities across
the country what i've noted what you see
in data is that there has been an
increase in crime since the start of the
pandemic i will let others assess what
the reason for that increase in crime is
that is all i was conveying yesterday
and medical affiliate district attorney
larry krasner now profusely sorry for
downplaying the crime crisis there
i did not
acknowledge
the pain
and the hurt
that people feel in the city of
philadelphia my words
unintentionally hurt people
it was never what i wanted to do
it's not the work that we do every day
it's not the work we will do the rest of
today what happened to uncle larry
sounds like an apology i've given before
jessica is extremely sorry that my
comments were misinterpreted in any hurt
that i've caused come on larry and just
so sake knows
the crime rate in philly especially
homicides have gone up since 2018 every
single year and i remember i think the
coronavirus started in 2020. so that has
nothing to do with the coronavirus but
good thing uncle larry has the press
because the philly enquirer came out
today you're not going to believe what
the headline was republicans pounced
when d.a larry krasner said philly
doesn't have a crisis of crime they
pounced
it's about republicans pouncing so i'm
looking at the fences being put up and
then i remember joe biden put up a fence
outside his delaware vacation home i
think nancy put up a fence around the
capitol they put up a fence around the
mansion here for de blasio we were told
fences were racist and now fences are
fine it's just like everything that
we've seen you know it's always like oh
you know what maybe the travel ban
wasn't racist uh maybe defining the
police wasn't such a great idea it's
like the definition of a conservative is
watching other people make the mistake
you warn them about right this is where
we are right now that's so true you have
to fight crime you can't just accept
crime as part of your life democrats
don't understand it people are going to
keep committing felonies you just have
to lock them up and make sure that they
don't keep doing that sadly it's going
to take some really high profile person
probably won't probably you could have
the d.a little larry's da's wife get her
jewelry snatched from some guy he just
let out on low bail and the democrats
still wouldn't do anything differently
until they lost an election that's the
only thing on crime that's going to
change that i really couldn't stand
making accommodations for the thieves by
putting up the fence yeah but i mean uh
just uh what to jesse uh you know the
wife of music legend yeah was murdered
in l.a do you think that made any
liberal change in their mind i know
because it didn't happen to their family
um yeah barbed wire is what happens when
you accept broken windows right and then
barbed wire's what happened when you
have fewer police cars out there no
police foot traffic no no no appearance
of law enforcement which is what we were
told was going to be a really good thing
so and you see this i mean you see this
in every bad area of town where they
have the junkyards you got barbed wire
and you got pit bulls because that's the
only disincentive left when the cops are
no longer there i mean this is basically
if you want say if if the cities and the
defunders want sanctuary cities for
criminals we should let him have it just
go let's say okay and then everybody
just move out let him have the road
warrior you know dystopian universe and
just let it go rather than taking these
little baby steps to uh what's his face
krasner
his playing he you know the apology is
way too late because there are a lot of
people dead in philly because of the
down playing that enabled the crime wave
you have de blasio you have left-wing
da's who who
and
obviously don lemon and chris cuomo on
cnn denying the crime wave actually
mocking us
mocking us on television saying it
didn't exist meanwhile who were dying
minorities most most of these victims
are minorities they're not whites so
that you know so it's like you wonder if
these da's or if these people at cnn are
actually racist because it's like how
they defend abortion you know but the
abortion takes more black unborn lives
as a percentage than white and they
couldn't be happier they couldn't be
happier so maybe underneath this all is
this their way the left-wing way of
cleaning society from a racial
perspective right those they're
disgusting yep i'm making that grow
that's disgusting they are yeah and
that's who gets hurt that's who elected
eric adams as the mayor who got him the
nomination in in yeah when you look at
them last spring it was the bronx yeah
queens yeah brooklyn uh people of
colorado
was latinos and a black individuals and
families not the snots
with the humpscalades living in the
doorman building in manhattan so if eric
adams i i might have said this yesterday
i don't know i've got the
fruit fly
if eric adams starts going out and just
locking people up
what's the governor going to say about
it no
what's the you know what's if they just
start going out and just start arresting
people you steal anything we're taking
you and just start could that definitely
will begin sending a message because i
think that it's not just the tolerance
for
egregious covert restrictions that has
topped out but also the tolerance for
skyrocketing crime new york city i read
this in the new york times today
regained fewer than six out of ten jobs
during lost during the pandemic the
nation as a whole has regained more than
nine out of ten i say that's because of
crime people will not get on subways and
commute to work the very people who need
protection and this is the making of
that suck hole that financial suck hole
that cities cannot get out of once your
tax base leaves and once you have really
high unemployment
michael nutter is a former mayor of
philadelphia he's one of the people that
came out so strongly against what
krasner had said and maybe that's what
really made the difference and made
krasner finally apologize with krasner
it is the most homicides well over 500
in philadelphia history in the history
of the city of brotherly love it is
extraordinary how you know and all like
virtually all african-american men i
mean it's it's horrifying uh when
krasner made one of his uh
pronouncements was when they had they
found four people uh in southwest philly
shot execution style
in one house
i want to say two quick things number
one is uh with the with the
retail thefts the the gang thefts we
need
massive rico
investigations all these kids
coordinated they say by social media so
they've arrested a handful you take the
handful you find their social media you
trace the social media till you can bust
one get one network do one high-profile
uh
prosecution at the federal level of of
these gang bangers
send a message unmistakably that if you
conspire then we will use rico against
you it just escalates the governmental
uh response i i think also that we need
a non-lethal way of preventing these
mass retail thefts and the idea i had
was and and you can mock me as you often
do but i i believe that uh you know how
they when you when you rob a bank you
put the cash in the bag when you open
the bag it blows up in your face and
it's like neon
it's pink it's green you can't get it
off it's all over the money it's all
over your salad you can't you can't sell
it and do that you can't sell the gucci
bag anymore
i i i stink bombs so everything's smooth
something like that
why not you know what a button where you
could press and they spray
stuff how about you give me the mask
mandates to the people wearing masks you
know are criminals that's a good point
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else